welcome back Democrats being accused of
focusing on partisan politics while
millions of Americans suffer during the
pandemic Nancy Pelosi ramping up
personal attacks on President Trump
take a look we have these comments
coming out of the White House the
president has been responsible and we
have insisted on the truth I'm
embarrassed sometimes about what how the
president talks he's crude in that and
you don't want children to hear that but
this is dangerous this is dangerous
and congressman Adam Schiff sensing the
need for new round of investigations the
Democrat going as far as comparing the
president's coronavirus response to
impeachment watch this the strongest
echo of what we were talking about
during the trial was when he was earlier
talking about how he didn't want to
return the calls from governor's he
didn't want his Vice President to return
calls from governors that weren't saying
nice things about him that was such a
profound and disturbing echo of what he
tried to do with Ukraine so sadly you
know as we pointed out during the trial
a man with no moral compass will never
find his way and this president
certainly hasn't all right Dana I want
to start with you while so many are
suffering economically what is your
perspective on speaker Pelosi's
anti-trump messaging and what effect
that might have on the election as we
approach campaign season closer well we
are gonna have politics so we're just
gonna have to deal with it and accept it
that there's going to be Barb's thrown
from both sides but on the merits I
think one of the things that Adam Schiff
was trying to do there was to remind
everybody that he was the one that led
the charge on impeachment because nobody
talks about impeachment or Adam Schiff
anymore so that was a way for him to get
back in the news the other thing is that
for example Chuck Schumer has said that
they're going to introduce legislation
to remove president Trump's names from
being put on any of the future stimulus
checks because one of the things that
the Democrats fell into is that they
said that the president's name being on
the checks made there be a delay in
getting the checks out well that turned
out not to be true but now that
Schumer wants to try to pass legislation
that says that the president can't put
his name on checks that's actually going
to delay checks getting out so I think
on the merits they keep getting sort of
nipped from behind by their own deeds
however I will say this I do think that
Congress has a role and it should be a
bipartisan role for oversight and how
all of this money is going to be spent
and doled out there we would have insist
on it
for any administration and I think that
everybody should want to know and have
accountable where this money is going to
be spent because we do want to help
people we want to make sure that money
gets to the people that actually need it
all right Jesse so we pay the salaries
for these guys and would you say that
it's deserving of our tax dollars that
Schumer is as Dana pointed out taking
more time for these relief checks
because he doesn't want the president's
name on them it's kind of ticky tack you
know it gets a headline I don't actually
think it's going to even happen it
really will delay it and then you can
really pin job losses on crunch up but
you just really can't trust Democrats
with power
they always abuse it and then they just
collude with the media and spread lies
to the American people like they're
still saying that the president said the
virus was a hoax they're saying the
president told Americans to drink Lysol
they're saying the president's going to
delay the election this stuff is crazy
it's like having children and every kid
is going to room to room to room in your
house making a mess and you're just
following them room to room and having
to clean up after them all the time and
you can't get any work done because they
never learn and they never listen and
that's what it's like dealing with the
meeting happening that you're just gonna
do it every single time perhaps it is
and perhaps that was me just kind of
getting something off my chest but in
reality it's what they do and that's
what they're going to do with these
oversight committees you know you're
gonna see them subpoena leak and lie
just like they did with Russia collusion
and we're gonna have to then fact check
it and
administration's gonna have to waste a
lot of manpower money and time fixing
all the mess and how bad is it going to
be compared to the last allegation that
he was a traitor I mean it can't be that
bad the best they're gonna get is that
money went to the Trump Organization
somehow someway and what they're gonna
do is they're gonna find money that went
to a guy that ten years ago had a
contract to mow the lawn at Bedminster
and they're gonna jam up some splashy
headline that makes it look like Trump
got money and then we're gonna have to
correct it and then they're gonna move
on to the next room and make a mess
there all right so one for the
bird's-eye view perspective as we've
been talking about 26 million Americans
are now are unemployed how is this the
action we need or effective leadership
if people like Adam Schiff are going
around saying they're gonna launch an
investigation into the coronavirus
response well I think there's inevitably
going to be some kind of 9/11 style
Commission but you know to me when you
have the Los Angeles Lakers getting
money that's intended for small
businesses there are a billion dollar
enterprise when the most valuable sports
Enterprise in America they got money and
they had to return it or you hear about
you know Ruth's Chris tour Shake Shack
any of these big companies about anybody
who's tied in to Morgan Stanley and all
the big banks getting preferential
treatment or today hearing about people
just looking for more help and the
computer system breaks down gosh if this
was the Obama administration there'd be
lots of screaming and calls for
accountability and you'd say that's
right we need accountability we need
government that really serves the people
so to me that's that's not an issue to
me it's about at this point what you're
getting is the Trump administration
having botched and been slow and so much
of the response looking for scapegoats
and so they point at people like oh
let's go back to Adam Schiff we don't
like Adam Schiff we feel like we
defeated Adam Schiff Adam Schiff wants
attention the fact is they're trying to
point the finger and distract people I
think from their own failings all right
Greg what are your thoughts
well we feel like Jessie having to go
back and clean up a room after Juan
spews that nonsense about everything
happened so late
let's remind everybody that he closed
down travel and it was the Democrats
that called him a racist for that also I
would love to see an investigation in
how this virus came about the media
couldn't even bother to ask that instead
they were defending China and defending
them by accepting the facts that they
were giving and were totally okay with
the fact that they were covering it up
this is a virus that came from a
combination of like bats and paying the
lynn proteins
we don't even know where it's from if
it's from a lab it was at biowarfare
I have no idea I'm assuming it was a
mistake it is it natural or is it
artificial but these are questions that
don't interest the media number three
point nobody's going after Adam Schiff
Adam Schiff is inserting himself into
this story
remember he launched this horrible
impeachment nightmare adventure that
tied up the government in the media and
we asked ourselves on the five what damn
story was being missed when this was
happening it was the corona virus there
was a hearing on the virus nobody showed
up because they're all getting their
questions ready for the damn hearing on
impeachment so we're gonna actually
allow the ringleader that put our
country in jeopardy that almost
potentially ruined our economy because
he was chasing his whale of an
impeachment you got to be out of your
body that's like deep he's like a dude
who gets arrested for a DUI and three
hours later he's back in the car driving
drunk we got to take the keys away from
Adam Schiff he's an embarrassment